[Music]
our main story tonight concerns
sandwiches specifically subway
sandwiches dad's attempt at dinner now
it can seem like subways in the news
pretty often and it is rarely for
anything good
fast food chain subway being sued for
fraud accused of selling tuna
that isn't actually tuna ireland's
supreme court says subway's bread can't
legally be called bread because it
contains too much sugar subway customers
are filing lawsuits against the global
sandwich chain saying its foot long
sandwiches aren't really a foot long
these are the shocking pictures that
started everything they were posted on a
social media site and one shows a man
putting his genitals on what appears to
be subway bread dough with the caption i
will be your sandwich artist today
look
blood or not that penis isn't even the
most defensive part of that photo look
at the bread it looks like a child's
drawing of ed sheeran and the sad thing
is you know just by touching the bread
with that penis the penis is ruined
forever
he's got no choice but to just throw it
in the trash but of course when you hear
pr nightmare for subway your head
immediately goes to this man jared he
was the face of subway for 15 years
after claiming that he lost 200 pounds
thanks in part to eating subway every
day he even featured in used puff pieces
like this one to play a lot differently
in hindsight
jarrod takes his pants on the road 200
days a year speaking to kids about
nutrition
everybody needs to make sure they make
really really good healthy decisions
every day so they never ever put
themselves in a position to have to wear
jared's old pair of pants
yeah you heard him kids stay out of
jared's pants nothing good happens in
there
subway has clearly been on the receiving
end of a lot of terrible stories and to
deal with each one just quickly jared is
a monster and subway should have always
been suspicious of a man willing to eat
their terrible product every day not
quite a foot long that is a [ __ ]
lawsuit it didn't go anywhere dodong
that did happen and it's objectively
funny ireland's court ruling that subway
spread can't be called bread the company
insists subway's bread is of course
bread and if you are curious about the
tuna you can just visit subway
tunafacts.com a real website the company
felt it had to launch to debunk tuna
myths although the moment that you've
done that it does feel like you're
already losing the argument
but even putting all of those stories
aside subway is still worth talking
about tonight for a number of reasons
starting with the fact it's a lot bigger
than you might think subway is actually
the biggest restaurant chain in the us
by number of locations and for a while
they had the most locations of any
restaurant worldwide beating both
starbucks and mcdonald's but in recent
years things have taken a turn thousands
of its restaurants have closed and some
franchisees that's the people who own
and operate their restaurants are
getting restless here in the us a
hundred of them got together and wrote
an open letter last year stating that
for many of us this dream has turned
into a nightmare and overseas
franchisees have given interviews like
this
our franchisees frightened people
terrified i feel threatened
because i'm scared if they target us
franchisees claim many want to get out
but say they can't because head office
won't approve it unless expensive
refurbishments are done
we want to escape but they make it
impossible for us to sell
holy [ __ ]
you know it's serious when they use a
voice modulator that can only be
described as auto-tuned andre the giant
and remember this is about a restaurant
that sells ham sandwiches what's the
worst subway could do to that man make
him eat one
and if your franchisees are giving
interviews like they're in witness
protection and the public is constantly
debating if your bread is bred your tuna
is tuna and whether or not your
sandwiches are filled with dicks
something has clearly gone very wrong so
tonight let's talk about subway where it
came from what its business model is and
why there are so [ __ ] many of them
and let's start with a little history
subway was founded as a single sub shop
called pete's super submarines back in
1965 by fred deluca who ran the company
until his death in 2015. and to give you
just a sense of what kind of manager he
was the company once distributed a
literally not safe full work calendar to
its employees featuring photos of
shirtless subway executives
including fred as mr january and i have
a lot to say about this the least
important of which is why is this guy in
a bathroom
the theme is clearly business but make
it nipples not polaroids of uncle dale
before a scrub down anyway from the very
beginning deluca was absolutely obsessed
with expansion even though the business
didn't make a profit for 15 years he
kept opening subways anyway in order to
as he later said create the image of
success so it really seems that subway's
business strategy was basically fake it
till you make it which apparently our
lawyers say i cannot suggest also
applies to their tuner so i won't i will
not suggest that
the point is
deluca had an insatiable desire for
growth which may be why in the mid 70s
subway moved to the franchise model the
benefit for the company being that they
could have more locations that way and
the benefit from franchisees
theoretically being that they could sell
an established product with brand
recognition with the promise of being
their own boss and there's actually one
other key draw about subway specifically
and that is just how simple it is to
open one subway's extreme ubiquity all
comes down to their streamlined setup no
deep fryers no gas grills so they can
build pretty much anywhere got a plug
that's practically all it takes to open
a subway
it's true you really don't need that
much to open a subway although i'm not
sure quite how reassuring it is that all
you need is a plug after all it is a
restaurant serving human food not an air
mattress
but subway startup costs have indeed
been significantly lower than many of
its competitors it usually costs between
around 200 and 500 000 to open a subway
compared with the mcdonald's which can
cost between 1.3 and nearly 2 and a half
million and that might help explain why
subway owners tend to be individuals and
families many of them immigrants unlike
chains such as mcdonald's where many
restaurants are operated by investment
firms but that low entry fee comes with
some significant catches first subways
bring in a lot less money than other
chains an average one generates around
four hundred thousand dollars a year
compared to the average jimmy john's
which brings in more than double that or
an average mcdonald's which generates
over three million but on top of that
subway franchisees also have to pay a
lot more of what they make back to their
company because while mcdonald's asked
its restaurants to pay them eight
percent of gross sales subway demands
twelve and a half percent specifically
an eight percent royalty fee and another
four and a half percent that goes toward
advertising those are some of the
highest fees of any chain although i
will say subway puts those ad fees to
heavy use because they are the reason
that you can't turn on your tv without
being bombarded by commercials featuring
steph curry tom brady and megan rapino
pretending they're all standing in the
same place and willing to put sloppy
bread cannons into their godbods
and it's not just ads subway has done a
significant amount of product placement
in shows and movies like the biggest
loser to all the boys i've loved before
and chuck i was even part of one of them
years ago in an episode of community
which i have zero memory of filming but
unlike my forgettable days as a
corporate sandwich vessel some of that
placement is pretty hard to miss like in
this incredible scene from hawaii 5.0
this subway sandwich
so oma okay so you're eating these to
lose weight is that is that right it
worked for jared and that boy was large
but the best thing about it they make it
any way you want it
check this one
sweet onion chicken teriyaki with
jalapenos with banana peppers now you
put that with this
turkey blt bam
there's some serious culinary fusion
you know
that scene reminds me of an old
hollywood saying every ad exec wants to
be a television writer and every
television writer is dead in sight
but incredibly even that is subtle next
to the product placement the subway
engages in overseas particularly in
korean dramas where every plot point
seems to occur at a subway here is two
characters having a meeting at one here
is a group of men celebrating the fact
real plot point by the way their friends
just woke up from a coma then there is
this scene which is i swear i'm not
making this up about a ghost magically
eating a subway sandwich
subway even released its own mini drama
on youtube called sunway and i'm going
to show you a scene from it now and i
warn you
it is breathtaking
oh
[Music]
it's good i mean it's really good
and not that you need it but here is
some context that character was dating
this guy who works at subway and every
day she ordered the plant-based sandwich
because he recommended it to her until
one day this guy who wait for it also
works at subway recommended the steak
and cheese sandwich for her to mix it up
the sandwiches were a metaphor you see
now she had a decision to make stay with
her usual or go with a new flavor which
will she choose plant or steak tried and
true or new and exciting obviously she
chose the steak which is why we got that
kiss in front of a subway franchise its
art and its cinema and its sandwiches
the point is
subway advertises a ridiculous amount
and its franchisees benefits from that
brand building but in return subway
expects them to work very hard something
made painfully clear in this video
created by a regional office which takes
a bit of a turn halfway through when you
buy a franchise you enter into a family
the subway family we must own what is
ours to own we must lead what is ours to
lead whether you sell sandwiches develop
stores or evaluate operations we must do
our part to the best of our ability why
because in this family people matter so
we don't let people down by being lazy
we don't complain about each other's
work we don't feel sorry for ourselves
and we certainly don't give up oh my god
it's a sandwich cult
and it's one that should probably think
twice about threatening their so-called
family members for being lazy when they
couldn't even put in the effort to
proofread their own copy because this is
not how you spell buy as in to buy a
franchise and they've left out the word
two in this sentence but whoever made
that video don't worry after all it's
only two little mistakes there's no need
to fell sorry for yourself
and the thing is there is only so much a
franchise owner can do to increase their
earnings as they are largely at the
mercy of decisions their parent company
makes so if subway decides to change the
menu or redesign the stores franchisees
may be on the hook for those costs also
if the company announces a promotion or
a discount stores may have to go along
with it even if it is a money loser for
them and it gets even worse because
those already ridiculously tight margins
have been exacerbated by subway's
long-time obsession with expansion for
decades franchisees have complained
about subway allowing locations to open
near each other and cannibalizing their
business in fact here is the head of a
franchisee association discussing the
problem back in the nineties
what they tell you when you buy that
franchise is don't worry we wouldn't put
another franchise too close to you why
would we do that why would we want to
hurt you like that you're one of our
partners reality is they're going to do
whatever they can do that's not written
in black and white and they do it okay
first that is some very dramatic camera
work but also
power bangs is completely right there
in fact to this day subway franchisees
are told that you will not receive an
exclusive territory and their contract
states we and our affiliates have
unlimited rights to compete with you
meaning a subway could open right next
to yours and cut your sales in half and
none of this really affects subway
corporate they still get their royalty
fees on any sale plus a fifteen thousand
dollar franchise fee for every new store
that's opened that is why these stores
are [ __ ] everywhere there are
literally ten subways in a one mile
radius of where i am sitting right now
you could go to all 10 stores order a
foot longer each and be back here in
less than an hour and the reason i know
that is
i did that and frankly
i'm instantly regretting my decision
because now this entire studio is about
to smell like a subway which as we all
know is the exact smell of what if bread
could fart and
all of this
all of this was by design fred deluca
even once attempted to convince a
journalist that more subway locations
raises everyone's revenues by
referencing a graph his 24 year old son
made which an economist later reviewed
saying in my view this tells us
absolutely nothing
if this is true then why not have 15
subways on the same block wouldn't they
all be doing splendidly the answer is
obviously not and that is a lot of sass
coming from an economist
the answer is obviously not it's much
like subway's spicy italian sub not
actually spicy in the least but given
the sauce about as spicy as you're gonna
get
and encroaching on their own territory
isn't the only way subway has angered
franchisees because their corporate
structure has long involved something
called business development agents these
are individuals often franchise owners
themselves who control a certain area
and are tasked with finding and
approving new people to open stores
getting a cut of royalties for doing
that they're also in charge of
overseeing inspections of stores in
their area and for many years
franchisees have complained about
development agents being exceptionally
harsh with those inspections with one
saying he was once marked up for slicing
his vegetables in a choppy manner which
seems pretty petty how else would you do
it
and there is an incentive for
development agents to be overly harsh
because if a store gets multiple
violations that franchisees agreement
can be terminated and the store can be
resold sometimes to the business
development agent themselves at a
discounted price
one former inspector even described a
development agent telling her the exact
store owners that he wanted to fail
adding i was kind of his hitman you know
normal sandwich stuff
now i have to tell you subway insist is
transitioning away from using
development agents in the us and from
having them be the ones overseeing
inspections but even so you might well
be wondering given everything you've
seen so far why on earth would anyone
want to open a subway when it has some
of the highest royalties some of the
lowest sales and a new store could
conceivably open right next door to you
well crucially potential owners often
don't fully know what they're signing up
for here is one subway franchisee
inadvertently making this point
i bought my original store from a guy
who was involved with subway had been
involved for about five years before me
and that store
little did i know was the lowest volume
store in the market when i went to my
first owner's meeting him and his buddy
said hey lollipop and i said why are
they calling me lollipop and they said
well we needed a sucker to buy columbus
which was the subway right
out of 91 stores in the market it was
91st
yeah that's not great is it ideally you
would have that kind of information
before you invested it's hard to tell
how successful a subway is just from
looking at it especially because from
the outside they all look like the worst
one
currently there is no easy way to find
out what you might earn before you open
a new subway for two reasons first the
company won't tell you generally when it
comes to franchises the ftc requires
that you are provided with what's called
a franchise disclosure document giving
you important information before you
invest but it doesn't require companies
to include any details about how stores
do financially now some companies do
provide this but it's voluntary
firehouse subs for instance has 17 pages
dedicated to financial performance
burger kings includes 11 pages but
subway has just two paragraphs in which
they say we do not make any
representations about a franchisee's
future financial performance or the the
past financial performance of franchised
outlets instead fred deluca encouraged
potential owners to simply do this you
know what we really want people to do is
go find out from other franchisees
rather than relying on what we might
tell you it's much better experience to
talk to 10 20 franchisees some will be
doing very well some won't do very well
and
you can then size up the business
yeah or you could just tell them instead
of making them go to 20 different subway
stores i guess luckily for them you can
find 20 of them on any one block in
america but it's really the principle of
the matter here but getting accurate
info can be very hard to do for starters
some franchisees may be reluctant to
speak because a few years ago subway
added an aggressive non-disparagement
clause in their contracts and while it's
true that there is now a carve out
saying you're not prohibited from
sharing information in good faith with
any prospective franchisees as one of
them told congress a few years ago many
are reluctant to trust someone calling
and asking questions and for obvious
reasons
so
people always talk about doing due
diligence in the industry
before they buy a franchise well one of
those parts of the due diligence is
calling existing owners most franchise
agreements have that non-disparagement
clause in it i can tell you if i'm in
one of my stores and somebody calls me
and starts asking questions and let's
say i have a negative experience am i
going to really say so i don't know
who's on the other end of the line
exactly you have no idea who might be
calling it's frankly all the more reason
why you should just never answer your
phone
calling people is for divorcees and
serial killers i haven't answered my
phone in 10 years now either text me or
forget me
and look
lots of the problems you've seen tonight
exist in some form with almost all
franchises but subway in particular
seems like the absolute worst and for
years their store owners have begged
them to be less restrictive with some
even releasing that open letter last
year complaining about many of the
things that we've mentioned tonight and
alleging whenever they've spoken out
about any of these issues to the media
they've been silenced by cease and
desist letters biased arbitrations and
forced non-disclosure agreements but
rather than listening to that subways
made things even worse for them they
recently updated their contract for new
and renewing franchisees which among
other things expands the
non-disparagement clause to include
subjecting the subway brand to ridicule
which come on subway
you are the one who made your new logo
to arrow 69 in each other
the call is coming from inside the house
here
it is frankly no wonder one restaurant
industry expert said no one in their
right mind would sign the new agreement
so what can we do here well i know that
your instinct might be to now never go
to your local subway it may have been
your instinct before this segment began
and honestly it remains a good one but
it's worth remembering some have spent
their life savings on these stores
believing the promise they could be
their own boss and are now stuck in a
business model that was stacked against
them from the start and to prevent that
happening to anyone else there are
things that we absolutely should be
doing to better regulate all franchises
the ftc should tighten up their rules on
them and make disclosing financial
performance mandatory that would force
companies to give a much fuller picture
to any potential investors of what they
are getting into but until that happens
or subway specifically decides to
present a more accurate picture of how
they operate maybe we can tell their
story for them through their favorite
medium i'm talking of course about
korean sandwich dramas please
take a look
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
foreign
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's our show thanks so much for
watching we're off next week we'll be
back june 5th good night
you